- What's the worst gift you ever got?
- Worst gift.
- Well, one year my older
son tricked my younger son
and wrapped up a bunch
of avocados, bananas.
So he essentially got
fruit salad for Christmas.
(others laughing)
Yeah. That was, it was funny.
- [Melissa] Well, it was
healthy. It was a healthy gift.
- [Nia] A healthy gift!
- There you go, optimism.
- Silver Lining Melissa.
- No, I got a great gift from my sister.
I won't say it's the worst gift.
It was kind of like double, double whammy.
Okay, she gave me a pair of shoes,
but then I opened the
box and they were worn.
I was like, well, wait,
did, did you wear these?
She was like, "Well, you
said you liked them."
I was like, I.. but.. did they not?
They were worn, but I loved them.
So I still wore 'em. I still kept it.
- [Morris] There's silver
lining, silver lining.
- [Nia] Did she go to the club
the night before gave you the shoes?
- I think she had worn them to school.
She had worn them all over the place.
- [Nia] Oh, wow.
- And I told her I liked them,
but I didn't know that I
would get the same pair.
- That's not right.
Regina, what about you?
- [Nia] That's not right, she said
- You know, I didn't get, you know what?
My brothers used to take my gifts
and give them to their girlfriend.
- [Kelly] What?
- Yeah. I had a brother that would take,
the girlfriend would
come over and be like,
"Look what your brother got me."
And I was like--
- [Nia] That's horrible.
- Isn't it?
It's horrible.
- [Nia] That's terrible.
- Yeah. But that's what happens. Look.
Kelly is like.
- That's how Regina looked
when it used to happen.
She was confused.
- [Regina] That was, that's right.
- This is really bringing Kelly down.
Don't come to our houses.
- Did you ever
call your brothers out?
Did you ever call them out?
Like in front of them?
- Of course.
Oh, not in front of the girl.
No, I never could do it
in front of the girl.
I would just go to 'em like.
- She's so loyal.
- I know.
I couldn't do it in front of the girl,
but I told my mother and my father.
(audience laughing)
- And they did nothing.
- They did nothing.
- They would say "stop
taking your sister's."
I mean, they just got verbal reprimands.
- What about you, Taye?
What about your worst gift?
- A pack of gum,
Bubblicious gum, one time.
That was my worst gift.
- Wow. What, you didn't like Bubblicious?
- I wanted--
- I like Bubblicious.
- [Nia And Melissa] I do too.
- Bad-ass bubbles!
- I love Bubblicious.
- Not for Christmas!
(audience laughing)
- No, that's like,
that should have been
like a stocking stuffer.
- Something along those lines, yeah.
- I never had a stocking.
- I never had, we
couldn't afford all that.
- We got the gift.
- Never had a?
- I never had stocking.
- [Nia] No stocking.
Very few ornaments.
- Kelly welcome to the hood, okay?
(all laughing)
- No, I grew up--
Hey, y'all are talking to someone
who grew up with no money.
- Sorry Kelly.
- I didn't grow up with any
money, but it's called credit.
My parents would put stuff on credit.
- We didn't get credit.
We didn't, we didn't even have that.
- One time my father
gave my mother a photo
of what she was gonna
what he was gonna get her.
- Oh my God.
- She liked it, she liked it.
It was a nice desk.
It didn't ever arrive, but.
- My mother was really good at layaway.
- Oh god, me too!
- Yes, layaway.
She be like, "We gon' put it on layaway."
- There's no more layaway.
They should bring layaway back.
- But your mother was good,
did she pick it up off of the layaway?
- Most of the time.
It took a while, it took a while.
- But you got it.
- That last payment was awesome.
(all laughing)